[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui je les lui wayne on s'est vraiment
bien écrit c'est bien pensée on sent la
plume un la plume bisous l'afutt donc
voilà bertrand les dossiers que vous
m'avez demandé
j'en ai plus besoin c'est bertrand je
suis fabrice ça fait trois ans que je
fais des cafés suis votre stagiaire
c'est vexant commun tous ses moyens vrai
j'aurais rêvé du nouveau oui hanouna sur
lci émission médias ça existe encore
eksi faut croire je me regarde qui
tenait et alors qu'est ce qui s'y est
dit regardez est ce que l'un des
nouveaux chroniqueurs alors louis
brochen
on va toujours gardé l'ossature voilà
qui en place mais on va faire émerger de
nouveaux journalistes télé voilà et pas
michel oui sinon mark rutte l'année
prochaine oui ça veut dire qu'il sera
toujours à la tête de l'émission
et s'il est toujours à la tête de
l'émission c'est à dire que c'est pas
moi qui la présentera non non donc vous
êtes venu me flinguer l'après-midi en
clair non mais il ya autre chose il ya
autre chose de ne plus croustillant de
deux plus forts même valérie bénaïm que
j'adore mais voilà qui j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'elle fasse quelque chose en
plus voilà sur la chaîne face profil
aussi ça pourrait elle se profile ouais
ouais j'ai ce serait quoi on sait déjà
pas cherché j'ai bien envie qu'elle
fasse un ne peut-être une émission de
déco mais une nouvelle génération
d'accords
[Rires]
tu sais un peu comme s'il donnait un
prime à bertrand chamerois sur d8
extrêmement humiliant ce que vous venez
de faire mais pourquoi parce que je
serai effectivement en prime sur d8 le
28 mai à 20h 55 cent vingt minutes de
bonheur en compagnie d'invités en public
avec de la musique des magnétos des
interviews chocs et chic
je vais préparer le prime parce qu'elle
avait la bagnole conclure j'aime eurois
prime sur des vite je fais n'importe
quoi cette chaîne
ça alors c'est lui l'assassin et voilà
le petit café avec les quatre sucre et
la petite touillette bertrand
commerciales n'ont pas fabrice qu'est ce
que c'est que cette merde je demande un
ristretto cdu rosa maia incapable
amateurs vous avez du nouveau bâti oui
oui j'ai du nouveau jet du nouveau
bagdad hanouna femmes
il va partir à chelsea il va jouer au
foot et jean foot
ouais ils vont le recruter jelle si
surveille baba foutez de ma gueule
hanouna vous pensez vraiment qu'ils
s'appellent baba c'est son surnom baba
c'est un joueur de foot d'un homonyme
crétins autre chose j'ai fait autre
chose vous y allez pas pensé depuis des
semaines mais hanouna pour entrer des 8
comment il fait dommage
il a un match on lui pique son badge
quick on le découvre hanouna il peut
plus rentrer évoqué d'or ah oui mais qui
sait qu'ils surveillent l'entrée un
débit by cc motards et mokhtari série
leçons et socopa et donc du coup
mokhtari va laisser rentrer ses copains
sert il allait donc ton idée sandra
c'est de la merde benzema mien
bon je vous préviens contre vous avez
intérêt à me sortir une bombe si l'on
jouir je voulais pas la sortir mais bim
ainsi l'unm bas il frappe à l'émission
demain avec ça késako c'est son casier
judiciaire
il est vierge oui mais c'est un casier
judiciaire mais il est vierge
oui mais c'est son casier judiciaire
mais il est vierge mais celle son casier
judiciaire comme un doux le monde a un
casier judiciaire crétin mais son casier
judiciaire
oui bon ben ça va on a compris c'est bon
fabien de la libye mais un bonhomme on
n'est pas un bonhomme pas me faire chez
moi je suis gentil je suis gentil mszp à
la bonne du curé
bon je vais faire un peu de vélo en
forêt de compiègne avec camille combal
ça me détend chez un peu soupe au lait
en ce moment et où camille qu'il est il
est pas là mais nous
[Musique]
ok
et tout ce qui me reste c'est juste une
photo de toi
brett wendeline tabriz fabris avaient
peu importe montrichard j'ai une idée de
génie
ouais vous allez le capturer ouaip ça je
serai définitivement débarrassé lui oui
le capturer ça vous trouvez bah oui au
bureau comme d'habitude excellent
mahmoud
vous savez où le trouver il déjà tous
les jours au même endroit à la même
heure vous me le ram est mort ou vif
plus vif que morts j'aimerais lui faire
passer un sale quart d'heure à base de
brûlures à vienne vous avez compris ah
oui ça va c'est beaucoup c'est pas con
quoi elle tient et voilà formidable
patricia nous fait un deux trois à luna
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
hillion le thème ma gueule dacquois je
vais demander de me ramener un animateur
du tpp
oui mais pas le remplaçant à celui du
vendredi
j'entends tout ce que vous dites là oui
mais moi je regarde pas en semaine je
fais votre ménage chez vous je ne peux
pas super mais là vous me mettez dans
une sacrée merde de c'est sûr que dans
une sacrée belle parce que je connais
encore moins des avocats mais tu sais
quoi
la régie va tout de suite en appelait la
fête au numéro